[Musique]
en
parler nous sommes avec georges
kuzmanovic présidents de républiques
souveraines bonsoir genre merci d'être
avec nous jean marc flipo porte-parole
de debout la france vont soir à vous
aussi tout d'abord georges osmanovic
quand vous voyez ce pompier qui d'une
certaine manière risque sa carrière
risque toutes les ambitions de son fils
qui rêve d'être en valeur
professionnelle qui finalement charge de
collèges qui ne le sera jamais parce
qu'il ne veut pas se faire vacciner ça
vous évoque quoi
vous savez je suis je trouve ça terrible
pour ce monsieur comme pour tant
d'autres qui vont se retrouver dans de
grandes difficultés d'autant plus que
nous sommes dans un contexte de crise
sociale économique qui suit la crise de
l'accueil des gens veut considérablement
emmanuel macron on a d'autres pays comme
nos voisins
très latin qu'ils sont que sont
espagnols qui sont très très largement
vacciner bien plus qu'en france sans
qu'il y ait autant de problèmes mais ils
ont eu un gouvernement qui a été qui n'a
pas menti qui a été honnête qui a dit
que quand ça n'allait pas ça n'allait
pas quand ils ne savaient pas ils ne
savaient pas nous on a eu un
gouvernement qui a tout fait qui a pensé
qu'on pouvait arrêter qui a dit qu'il
n'y en a pas de crise qu'il n'y aura pas
de contamination massive qui a dit après
que des flyers dans les aéroports
arrêterait les contaminations qui a dit
que les masques ça va rien puisque les
masques étaient dangereux et puis que
les masques étaient obligatoires il a
coûté 135 euros de ne pas en avoir et
puis qu'on pouvait on ne pouvait sortir
je ne pouvais plus sortir et puis on
pouvait on pouvait à nouveau sortir mais
en signant soi même sa propre
autorisation ce qui évidemment fait rire
à peu près toute la planète
on a un président qui ne croyaient pas
au vaccin là où par exemple de donald
trump a financé 40 6 milliards et qui
fait que nous avons les vaccins moderne
haifa isr après c'est en descendant de
ray ban pour qu'ils le disent assez
grasse a donné le 3 mai
suivie entre la politique et il ya les
affaires médiatiques et donne des choses
sont ne sont pas si différentes que ça
en particulier dans ce domaine
on a un président qui en décembre
dernier disait qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya dans le vaccin qui a nourrit
donc à la confusion chez les ch nos
concitoyens et puis qui tout à coup un
pause se passe
sanitaires
et en même temps
en faisant passer la réforme des
retraites tout à fait néolibérales
imposées par l'union européenne
s'attaquant à l'assurance chômage mais
ça s'est passé
oui mais ya des choses qui passent dans
les cavaliers pardon le parlementaire
donc ils font bien leur travail pour
saper nos retraites
et donc une obligation vaccinale de
facto mais dont sont exempts les forces
de l'ordre qui sont amenés à contrôler
si les gens ont bien fait alors la
vaccination à toute personne normale se
dit on est dans un pays de fous en tout
cas ceux qui le dirigent sont
complètement insensé et c'est bien c'est
bien normal puisque la campagne
vaccinale à être organisée par des
consultants donc notre google notre
président emmanuel macron a préféré ne
pas se baser sur les services compétents
d'état ou sur nos militaires qui savent
gérer des questions de crise mais sur
mac kinsey d'inquiétude qui tout à coup
c'est trouver très compétente dans la
domaine de la vaccination de masse ce
qui est tout à fait intéressant jean
marc flipo vous quand vous voyez
effectivement ce pompier c'est vrai que
quand on interroge dans ses motivations
d'ailleurs il a du mal à les exprimer
mais ça ne regarde finalement ça vous
inspire quoi vous vous dites une sacha
au contraire non il défend tout
simplement sa liberté ce monsieur il est
droit dans ses bottes ça m'inspire des
jeux une immense tristesse de voir que
ce paye en soit arrivé là je vais pas
revenir sur son inventaire que fait
monsieur qu'aux novices qui
effectivement avait un journaliste
allemand une journaliste allemande qui
avait qualifié tous adoptent kurdistan
il faudra juste savoir si c'est
uniquement de l'absurdité ou s'il ya un
moment donné il ya eu des desseins
cachés on commence à voir des ministres
défilent et la cour de justice de la
république pense on en a une je pense
que c'est un appelé à monter à monter un
petit peu plus haut sur l'obligation le
traitement qu'on inflige aux soignants
le traitement qu'on inflige aux pompiers
que star c'est un pur scandale et là
aussi ça pose ça posait pas de question
au mois de février mars avril 2020 on
les a envoyés en première ligne sans
rien
on se rappelle tous de ces images de
soignants en train de s'équiper avec des
sacs poubelles pour faire leur travail
en avait certains qui étaient contaminés
qui se savaient contaminées dont on a
exigé qu'ils aillent soigner leur malade
pourquoi parce que on l'a on a dit allez
pas pris mais ces gens la connaissent
les gestes barrières et savent se
produisent à protéger leurs patients pas
toujours des masques et en plus de ça
n'avait pas de matériel il faillit
faisait comme il pouvait mais à l'époque
on disait là ils savent tous à protéger
leurs patients alors aujourd'hui on les
accuse littéralement d'être des
criminels c'est insupportable vous avez
à peu près 300 milles soignants en
france qui sont dans ce cas là alors
qu'on manque de personnel alors qu'au
manque de lits mais il faut être
complètement fou pardon soit 90% des
soignants qui sont vaccinés oui mais ça
fait trois cent mille personnes qui ne
sont pas attention c'est que ça paie sur
le chu de nice les un article dans
nice-matin aujourd'hui sur le chu ni ça
représente des centaines de personnes
sur un seul chu mais je pense que vous
réalisez ce que ça va commencer le
système de santé français va être
impactée comment le système hospitalier
qui est déjà au bord de l'explosion on
va être impactée les ambulanciers avec
13% dambulla d'ambulanciers qui ne sont
pas vaccinés on commence à reporter les
prises en charge de malades est là pour
l'instant on parle que du club vide mais
quid des malades des couples de des
cancers quid des personnes qui doivent
aller se faire dépister pour d'autres
maladies enfin on est en train de on en
train de répéter
les erreurs qu'on a commises au début de
l'épidémie comme si rien ne s'était
passé et moi je pose la question parce
qu'on commence à entendre la petite
musique qui revient du 5e francon
l'arrêt combien 5/5 vague croit
maintenant
imaginons qu'on a un autre variante qui
arrive parce qu'on a laissé l'afrique
totalement non vaccinés ce qui est un
autre scandale absolument
inimaginable images ou
partie effectivement dans les pays
pauvres sur 4 milliards qui ont été
distribués dans les pays riches et vous
avez l'om est ce qui vient encore une
fois de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé avec
son directeur général le dr gabriel sous
ce mardi dernier en disant qu' il aurait
à peu près un quart des doses qu'ils
dont il avait besoin pour par des
prochains si vous laissez le terrain de
jeu au virus en afrique on peut très
bien leur invariants plus virulents plus
contaminant qui va revenir qu'est ce
qu'on va faire à ce moment là s'il veut
que si le vaccin n'est pas efficace où
sont les stocks de masques ffp2 où sont
les purificateurs où sont les lits
d'hôpitaux voilà on part dans un autre
débat mais clairement vous genre qu'on
se mette en cause mais de ricciardo
candidat à l'élection présidentielle on
le rappelle vous rendriez la vaccination
obligatoire aujourd'hui on entend cette
musique aussi aux états unis emmanuel
macron le 12 juillet dernier nous a dit
voilà ça va devenir un débat à la
rentrée clairement vous franchir y est
ce pas là aujourd'hui dans la trémie
collectif si j'avais été président
j'aurais pas fait toutes les inepties
café ce gouvernement avant et donc
l'autorité de la parole présidentielle
aurait été prise beaucoup plus de
sérieux
c'est là qu'est le problème c'est ce
gouvernement qui est la cause de ce
chaos
mais moi j'aurais été pour l'obligation
vaccinale mais en la faisant comme on
doit la faire c'est à dire en ayant nous
mêmes nos vaccins on ne les sent pas par
exemple le vaccin de fabriquer en france
de manière plus classique à
saint-herblain être achetés par les par
les britanniques nous aurions aussi
également investi pour
avoir d'autres vaccins et puis surtout
on aurait organisé de manière qui soit
acceptable par la population et non pas
en faisant pas solitaire qui se
transforme la moitié de nos concitoyens
policiers qui surveillent les autres
sont d'ailleurs avec une fraude massive
et donc sans que ce soit réellement
sérieux nous aurions proposé plus tôt eh
bien d'abord de vacciner le gouvernement
et le parlement et de le montrer et puis
ensuite toutes les personnes en grande
difficulté de communiquer là dessus
et vermont over ces travailleurs
survient et puis des soignants et puis
ensuite les forces de l'ordre puis les
pompiers puis les fonctionnaires en
contact avec la population et pas par
paliers pour que ce soit compris et
accepté par la population et pas dans le
chaos tel qu'il est organisé
actuellement donc oui et on voit
effectivement que ça commence à se faire
dans certains dans certains pays
voilà quand est ce que vous disiez par
rapport à l'afrique
est relié à votre question l'un des
problèmes c'est que à tort ou à raison
les citoyens ont le droit de penser ce
qu'il pense et certains ont peur du
vaccin et rennes même si c'est à tort
c'est légitime chacun est libre dans ce
pays et bien un gouvernement conséquent
aurait offert la possibilité soit avec
les vaccins fait en france à
saint-herblain loire-atlantique soit en
prenant des en achetant des vaccins
spoutnik v comme pensé le faire madame
merkel soit en achetant des vaccins
souveraineté de sault brénaz dos qu'à
fabriquer cuba qui est efficace à 92%
mais qui sont des vaccins qui fonctionne
à l'ancienne c'est à dire que c'est une
charge virale atténuée c'est pas de la
rn est bien de proposer à ceux qui
craignent la rn d'être vacciné de cette
manière on aurait eu évidemment beaucoup
moins de problèmes et pour l'afrique eh
bien cuba comme à l'époque vu de la
crise de l'ebola va offrir en licence
libre le vaccin souveraineté deux et ça
pose un autre problème qui est lié à
tous cette campagne d'action elle sait
que on se retrouve à acheter extrêmement
cher et sans aucun contrôle sur le
contenu des contrats puisque c'était
négocier comme une très libre échange
par la commission européenne à payer
très cher des doses
là où on aurait pu
obtenir pour moins cher si ça a été une
crise ayant fait ou si nous avions eu
d'autres options comme les vaccins que
j'ai cités pour en revenir à ce débat
vous avez commencé à montrer d'ailleurs
clairement la question oui pourvoi la
vaccination obligatoire mais fait
différemment jean marc flipo vous ça
vous choque vous n'êtes pas sur la même
ligne
l'obligation d'une vaccination c'est un
gros mot en vaut aujourd'hui oui c'est
un c'est un gros mot pour des tas de
raisons on peut comprendre ce qui se
passe aux etats unis parce que les états
unis sont un pays qui est en fait qui
est enfermé dans une espèce de jeudi si
harris mme extrême et ça arrive en
france puisque on est tous soudés à
devant ce qui se passe aux etats unis et
c'était edouard philippe qui l'année
dernière avait bien expliqué dans son
livre d'ailleurs qu'il y avait le risque
judiciaire ils prenaient tous les
ministres y compris le président de la
république prenez en compte ce risque
judiciaire et donc la vaccination
obligatoire on commence à avoir le
sentiment aussi que c'est peut-être un
peu pour ça mais nous sommes surtout
contre la vaccination obligatoire parce
que c'est le c'est la négation même de
la de la politique vaccinale au départ
faut pas oublier que le vaccin au départ
est développé pour prémunir celui qui le
reçoit de développer des formes graves
de la maladie ça c'est depuis les débuts
de la vaccination et ça a été le cas
dans toute l'histoire de la vaccination
à aucun moment on a imposé à des gens de
se faire vacciner pour protéger les
autres même si c'est inscrit depuis dans
le code de la santé publique dans le
code du travail il ya ceux de cette
notion de vaccinations altruistes
il n'empêche quand même pour l'hépatite
b on met toujours cet exemple là sur le
tapis pour les soignants même pour
l'hépatite b au départ il s'agissait de
de protéger les soignants de contracter
la maladie par leurs patients et non pas
l'inversé donc voilà et en plus de ça on
est aujourd'hui sur un vaccin qui ne
protège pas totalement de la
transmission de la maladie donc ce à
quoi on assiste c'est quoi vous avez des
gens et particulièrement dans la
jeunesse vous avez des jeunes qui sont
doublement vacciner mais qui commence à
faire la fête qui vont appeler des amis
pour faire la fête qui vont absolument
pas contrôler si le copain a été vacciné
par la cdci là un test pap test etc et
on est on relance en relance la maladie
comme ça donc ça n'a strictement aucun
sens il vaut mieux et d'ailleurs c'était
recherche va les skis la directrice du
site d'ici d'atlanta killer qu'il
rappelait au mois de juillet il vaut
mieux rester un peu plus longtemps avec
cette politique de geste barbare qu'est
là malheureusement il faut l'admettre
aujourd'hui le seulement les riverains
derrière c'est vrai que vous n'allez
plus au restaurant vous ne faites plus
de concerts du théâtre c'est compliqué
quand même geste d'ailleurs pouvait le
reste on avait justement il ya
d'ailleurs le gouvernement avait imposé
aux restaurateurs tout une toute une
usine à gaz pour se mettre en conformité
et du jour où ils sont mis en conformité
en ayant payé des sommes incroyables par
le faire on leur a imposé un confinement
général et la fermeture donc mais des
moyens il ya des moyens très concret
pour le faire et je suis désolé mais la
vaccination encore une fois c'est le
bénéfice risque c'est l'alpha et l'oméga
de la vaccination en tout cas galerie à
natal n'est pas de cet avis un temps
forcément le porte parole du gouverneur
lui l'a changé assure qu'elles sont
fonction du courant on va l'écouter
avant de vous donner la parole cher
george clooney est vrai la tête de neuf
soignants sur dix se sont fait vacciner
que beaucoup de chemin a été parcouru le
niveau national depuis l'allocution du
président de la république je le
rappelais à l'instant 64% au début du
mois de juillet près 90% aujourd'hui et
nous nous attendons en réalité est ce
que ce soit un peu plus parce que
certains soignants n'avait pas déclaré à
leurs employeurs qu'ils avaient été
vaccinés c'est aujourd'hui finalement
moment de vérité entre guillemets ou un
certain nombre d'entre eux feront
connaître leur statut vaccinal à leur
employeur on est satisfaits à ne pas
parler des gouvernements toujours c'est
une mais c'est une autre leur gabriela
talent qui n'a jamais travaillé commencé
très tôt au ministère de la santé où il
était sous françois hollande quand
madame touraine et ministre de la santé
il était avec monsieur verrons
monsieur salomon en tout le monde était
déjà là toute équipe était déjà là et ce
sont ceux qui sont les principaux
fautifs de la destruction de notre
réaction
nationale aux crises sanitaires alors en
dehors du vaccin pas vaccin nous n'avons
pas la même la même approche mais à
république souveraine nous avions à
noter dès fin février 2020 que en
observant sans avoir les moyens d'état
qu'a le gouvernement que les coréens
parce qu'ils ont un état qui gouvernent
ils ont des gouvernants qui gouverne
dans l'intérêt de leur pays qu'ils ont
une industrie qui peut faire des
respirateurs des masques ont combattu le
virus et sont sans avoir jamais rien
fermé sauf un mois parce qu'ils sont un
petit peu inquiétés ils ont fermé
pendant un mois en deux en un an et demi
des discothèques donc ne rien faire mais
leur économie est en très bon état par
rapport à la nôtre ont moins de trois
mémoires pour une population de 50 50
les restrictions quand même assez oui
attention les séries mais ça c'est des
miss cessa gouverner c'est prison ils
ont contraint parce que parfois il faut
compter 1 bertem un confinement
oui mais nous on avait un confinement
pour l'ensemble du pays pendant des mois
le il confine qui confinait les malades
pendant deux semaines et les gens qui
étaient autour d'eux et on voit que ça
fait beaucoup moins de casse tant
psychologique que que dans l'économique
mais donc gabriel attal a participé à
des sélections entre des épreuves donc
les établissements publics de réaction
aux urgences sanitaires toutes ces
choses là qui nous qui nous ont manqué
pour réagir à cette crise donc il est
vraiment très très mal indiqué de
s'exprimer sur ce sujet d'autant plus
que le directeur général de la santé
monsieur salomon lui huissiers des
palmes académiques donc lui il a une
responsabilité personnelle dans le fait
qu' il n'est signé pas suffisamment de
vaccins le pardon de masques dans le
pays il a utilisé ses pouvoirs ont
demandé à ses services de masquer sa
responsabilité ce qui a été repéré par
une commission sénatoriale et il a mal
tourné il n'a pas été démissionnée est
toujours la même celle gabriela talent
[Musique]
les noms de tout le monde c'est pas la
question mais moi je pour rebondir sur
la corée on a l'exemple de la france
métropolitaine en a les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé dans les dom tom ce qui
s'est passé dans les dom tom est un vrai
scandale là encore il fallait aller au
devant des populations parce qu'on
savait que ces populations étaient à
risque il y avait des facteurs de
comorbidité énorme et puis pardon mais
le par avec la corée du nord la corée la
corée du sud a coïncidé pas une ils
m'ont fait aller elle est tellement
isolés que c'en est quasiment une les la
guadeloupe la martinique la police sont
des îles mais n'a pas pris nos
frontières jusqu'à on aurait quand même
pu des choses qu'ils ont fait leur
accord est mieux les protéger c'est à
dire que variant les variants ils ont
été importées sur saisine on aurait
quand même plus là où il n'y avait pas
de diffusion de la maladie on pouvait en
avaient le devoir de protéger ces
populations là et comment j'ai entendu
olivier ferrante scepticisme tant en
outre mer sur la vaccination geste d un
énorme travail à faire là dessus il y
avait la sphère de clark et donne enfin
voilà il ya un passif aussi avec l'état
français aux antilles donc il faut
redonner confiance à ces gens là mais
moi quand j'ai entendu je conclurai là
dessus olivier ferrand prendre l'avion
pour aller à la martinique et dire que
il envisageait d'acheminer plus tard des
anticorps monoclonaux moi je suis désolé
mais nicolas dupont aignan président de
la république il prend pas l'avion sans
avoir une cargaison d'anticorps
monoclonaux dans là pour soigner les
gens dans la soute de l'avion merci à
tous égards du coup on a un petit peu
débordés dépassés au delà de ce débat
sur la vaccination obligatoire mais le
jeu merci en tout cas tous des deux
georges kosmatov beach et jean marc
flipo merci à vous et c'est là